Hãy đại tưởng bộ trường cố phòng Việt Nam và lâu cùng nha y sạp,
muốn làm vong nếu còn với người dân sẽ kiếm bằng.
Sáng mười tháng bẩy đã cơ khẩu thành thuyện nghe ăn,
đại tưởng phân văn dàng, phó thu tưởng bộ trường cố phòng Việt Nam,
đã trụ chỉ lễ đón đại tưởng kham liang U-Tà Kaison,
phó thu tưởng bộ trường cố phòng lâu.
Sau lễ đón, hãy đại tưởng cùng người dân giá gạo nha y sạp,
muốn làm vong chuyển thống của lâu và tham gia các hợp văn hóa.
Đây là một trong những hạt động của raul liều hiếm nghị của phòng biên giới Việt Nam
lâu lần thứ ba dễn ra trong hai ngày chiến và mười tháng bẩy,
tại tình nghe ăn Việt Nam và tình bố li căm sai lâu.
Các hạt động raul liều trước dễn ra vào các năm 2020 và hai nghiệm không trong hai miếm tư,
có phần thu hệ quán hệ hợp tác của phòng và các lực lượng bảo vệ biên giới giữa hai nước.